[Musique]
ismaila vannes bonjour bonjour bienvenue
pour ce café politique au bicycle heures
ce qui nous accueillent aujourd'hui vous
êtes conseiller municipal d'opposition
du parti socialiste à maurepas vous avez
été notamment lors de la précédente
mandature cette fois-ci conseiller
départemental elle des yvelines
malgré une situation difficile vous
restez au parti socialiste oui en tout
cas pour l'instant je reste au parti
socialiste pour l'instant parce qu'on
sait jamais comment les choses peuvent
évoluer il faut être faut être franc
mais je reste aux portes et socialiste
parce que déjà par fidélité comme vous
l'avez rappelé j'ai été conseiller
général c'était encore l'époque j'étais
conseiller général et j'avais été élu
sous l'étiquette du parti socialiste un
parti dans lequel je suis depuis que
j'ai l'âge de vingt de 20 ans et je
crois que la fidélité c'est important
aussi dans la vie en général mais aussi
un grand politique et je ne quitte pas
le navire comme ça donc je compte
participer à la reconstruction ça va
être très difficile mais me battre pour
que les valeurs auxquelles on croit
puisse émerger dans notre pays vous avez
été candidat pour la présidence de la
fédération des yvelines a aussi vous
représentiez plutôt la ligne plutôt à
gauche
[Musique]
effectivement dans une qui est plutôt de
la gauche
moi je suis quelqu'un de plutôt modéré
mais
j'aime sa ligne et j'ai toujours être
fêtée dans ce positionnement qui est
dans pour moi dans les fondements et
dans l'histoire du parti socialiste
aujourd'hui vous pensez que toutes les
lignes tous les courants peuvent se
retrouver au sein du parti socialiste
moi j'ai toujours pensé que le proscrire
et conquis réconciliables ce n'est pas
les courants c'est les hommes et les
femmes qui les composent le problème il
est essentiellement humains au parti
socialiste parce que si on prenait la
mesure de des choses la mesure de la
difficulté dans laquelle on est des
défis qui sont devant nous sociétaux et
environnementaux
on serait en capacité de dépasser notre
propre personnalité
nos petites guerres d'ego bah oui ça
c'est clair et net
si on fait un new deal aujourd'hui
socialiste et concis on veut qu'on
veuille vraiment s'y retrouver tous je
pense qu'on s'y retrouve et dans le
passé ça c'est déjà fait on a plein de
reprise le parti socialiste a toujours
été jalonnée de courants différents et
variés depuis plus de 100 ans
certains très à gauche d'autres un peu
moins certains même voulant me dire être
contrôlés système ça s'est déjà vu et
puis plusieurs fractures
mais ce qui a toujours été
décisif c'est que quand la gauche est
rassemblée à la dernier la fidélité pour
moi c'est quelque chose d'important
c'est comme un couple quelque part on
part quelques fois on a des difficultés
et on s'en va pas en tout cas moi dans
mon esprit dès les premières petites
embrouilles
donc il faut faire cet effort de mongla
de recollement de de synthèse de
reconstruction qui est nécessaire et
c'est très dur et les français nous
attendent et pour l'instant faut dire
les choses
nous ne sommes pas encore à la hauteur
vous avez commencé très jeune au parti
socialiste où vous êtes et militants des
jeunes socialistes oui pourquoi avoir
rejoint le ps lmj le mjs mouvement des
jeunes socialistes parce que je suis ça
c'est dans mon parcours de vie moi je
suis fils d'ouvrier
mon père était ouvrier on disait aux os
ouvriers spécialisés car on aubignan
rucka renault à boulogne billancourt
toute une histoire
cette ville de l'automobile et de
renault qui à l'époque l'état avait une
forte emprise dessus donc c'était
quasiment une entreprise d'état et donc
du coup il y avait ce milieu dans lequel
je baignais où mon père était ouvrier
donc dans la classe moyenne qui aspirait
à s'émanciper et en même temps ce
rapprochement avec une sorte entre
guillemets d'état providentiel puisque
renault nouissel non seulement la
famille mais aussi en bénéficier et
c'est ça qui est très important à
l'époque de structure d'entreprise qui
permettait d'aller en vacances de faire
des colonies des fans de la formation et
donc du coup ce n'est pas seulement mon
père qui travaille à renault finalement
nous aussi on y était intégrée donc
c'est un projet quasiment d'entreprise
de société et de vie qui était
extraordinaire
et pourquoi le gert-jan le parti
socialiste parce que justement je suis
issu de ce milieu ouvrier qui m'a permis
grâce après à la république française de
faire des études d'être aujourd'hui
ingénieur mais je n'ai pas oublier d'où
je venais et je crois que l'origine du
parti socialiste et de sa substance ce
qui le nourrit c'est ce milieu là et
c'est cette histoire là existe
aujourd'hui encore des convictions
fortes de gauche qui ont toujours été
présentes au sein de votre famille est
donc l'engagement politique était
et sur elle en fait tout à fait naturel
s'engager en politique et à ce moment là
votre famille vous a soutenu alors c'est
ça qui est extraordinaire c'est que j'ai
un père quand j'avais un père qui était
très militant très engagé
donc quelque part c'est peut-être lui
qui m'a donné cette fibre de
l'engagement alors il participe à la
plainte d'associations humanitaires donc
que cette fibre de gauche étaient
présentes chez moi et c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire dans les familles c'est
que
chacun chaque enfant vit à peu sa propre
vie sa propre expérience et on n'est pas
tous forcément d'aller dans les mêmes je
dirais courante ou sa bouche mais pas
forcément dans les mêmes courants et
c'est bien c'est ce qui aurait fait que
c'est la diversité et cette diversité
familiale qu'on retrouve probablement
faux parti socialiste sauf que parti
socialiste il est temps que la famille
se rassemble ça veut dire qu'il ya des
discussions animées
oui mais sympathique quels étaient les
sujets sur lesquels il y avait plus de
discussions entre ceux qui sont entre
guillemets gauche gauche est presque je
veux dire un mot qui est peut-être un
publiant contre le système parce que
c'est la jeunesse pour le refonder et
ceux qui sont beaucoup plus modérés dans
un accompagnement et une modification
des règles de manière douce on retrouve
finalement ces clivages familiaux dans
le parti socialiste la clé qu'elle est
jalonnée dans toute son histoire par ces
mêmes questions et c'est ça qui est
marrant
donc du coup la partie 2 le parti
socialiste encore une fois je reste
parce que c'est ma famille et j'ai envie
que ma famille se rassemblent quoiqu'il
il est temps de devenir sérieux quoi un
moment on va revenir à votre parcours
votre parcours et votre implantation
peut-être à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
aussi des communes que vous connaissez
bien vous couvrir nos repas manière mort
pas où vous résidez comment vous êtes
arrivé sur ce secteur je suis arrivée là
justement mon père donc on en a parlé
tout à l'heure au travail et à renault à
boulogne et il a déménagé à coignières
total a donc c'est comme ça que je suis
arrivé à coignières à l'âge de 6 ans et
j'y suis resté jusqu'à 30 ans pour aller
à maurepas conseiller municipal de
l'opposition aujourd'hui est forcément
vous regardez les dossiers qui
concernent sept communes y en a il y en
a plusieurs qui qui font discussions en
tout cas peut-être le rapprochement avec
coignières vous gagnez vécu dans les
deux communes l'avion mais oui mais oui
c'est vrai que pour moi ça me touche
particulièrement bras je vais être franc
une fusion c'est pas idiot le début
c'est pas idiot de faire une fusion
c'est dans l'air du temps beaucoup de
communes le font donc moi j'ai envie de
dire pourquoi pas parce que ça peut
amener une mutualisation s'il ya un
projet de territoire ça peut créer des
services supplémentaires ou plus
efficace à la population et c'est donc
pourquoi pas sur le principe
sauf que là je pense le maire actuel s'y
prend très mal
il y à des données dont lesquels il a
pas pris compte la première d'entre
elles c'est sa conférence de presse où
il annonce d'emblée c'est ce qui a écrit
en tout est écrit en tout cas dans les
journaux qu'il y aura fusion et qui ce
qu'il ne fait aucun doute que ce sera
adopté en conseil municipal et le maire
de coignières semestre de rajouter que
il n'y aura pas de référendum
voilà donc tout est plié d'avancé réglé
là où et c'est là notre proposition
on peut avancer beaucoup plus rapidement
avec les l'encours elancourt déjà la
ville a été structurée de telle façon
que au niveau de la frontière les
flottante les et reebok a voulu ça comme
ça donc c'est entre maurepas elancourt
on sait pas où on est elle a été
construite comme ça et ensuite il ya un
commissariat il ya des collèges il ya
des lycées il ya un nombre
d'associations phénoménal qui sont
répartis entre les deux communes et les
gens les des habitants des deux communes
ne vois pas trop la différence mais on
partage aussi au passage une piscine
donc je crois que cette fusion avec l
encours est beaucoup plus naturelle
beaucoup plus rapide à mettre en place
il ya d'autres dossiers dont on pourrait
parler l'émission est assez courte mais
peut-être ou même un mot concernant la
piscine la piscine de maurepas est en
cours
pour vous cette piscine il faut la
rouvrir la rénover rapidement on perd du
temps on perd parce que là on est parti
dans un projet de déconstruction
reconstruction des parties alors c'est
un projet qui est devenu politique alors
qu'il devrait être à la base comme
toutes les piscines de france carla 40
ans qu'elle arrivait un cycle de vie que
ça a été entretenue avant ou pas c'est
pas la question mais je pense que c'est
pas vrai je pense qu'elle a été
entretenue mais en tout cas il ya un
moment se pose la question de
l'habitation à maurepas nous
réhabilitons des collèges ils ont 40 ans
c'est normal dans ma résidence à moi où
j'habite on a réhabilité toute la dalle
de parking le bâtiment à 40 ans si vous
aussi vous été amené à lire l'audit de
mon bâtiment ou dans n'importe quel
bâtiment avant pas vous serez effrayer
mais non on pressent pas tout quand même
on réhabilite et la piscine rentrer dans
le même ordre de reconstruction que tout
autre établissement à maurepas
donc il fallait la réhabiliter mais on
perd du temps et on perd du temps
probablement pour des raisons politiques
aujourd'hui est financière parce que la
fermeture de la piscine a quand même
économie fait économiser près de 700000
euros par an à la commune donc ça il
faut le savoir
et ensuite
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on se lance dans
une déconstruction reconstruction dont
on n'a pas les chiffres
un coup c'est un million un coup c'est
dix millions c'est un projet qui n'est
pas ficelé 2020 approchant les élections
approchant consent une accélération et
une volonté de construire ce projet
coûte que coûte quitte à utiliser tous
les moyens de passer par le privé
il ya beaucoup de dossiers qui vous
occupe que ce soit les dossiers de la
piscine le parti socialiste à
reconstruire aussi vous arrivez à mener
votre activité professionnelle malgré
tout ouïe l'hyperactif l'ingénieur
l'ingénieur d'études en développement en
électronique et informatique pour
l'aéronautique et télécommunications je
travaille dans l'aéronautique
ces dernières années + dans le monde de
l'automobile et je travaille sur le
véhicule du futur donc sur le
développement des véhicules
à horizon 2020 2025 2030 pour terminer
cette émission questionnaire habituel
votre livre de chevet ah je m'attendais
pas il va tenter face à cette question
vous allez rire pour le compte d'une
association
je devais en fait récuse récolté plein
de livres pour les amener en afrique et
je suis tombé sur le parti socialiste
pour les nuls vraiment combien vous avez
appris beaucoup de choses je connaissais
déjà l'histoire mais je les prix j'ai
feuilleté parce que je me suis replongé
dans les années dans les origines de
parti socialiste en 1700 1800 l'histoire
de jaurès et de blum la scission qui a
créé deux partis le parti communiste et
je me suis dit c'est bien de se rappeler
un peu l'histoire du parti socialiste et
ce qui m'a étonné en relisant ce livre
je me suis dit c'est incroyable comment
l'histoire se répète pas elle même
quasiment son temps jour pour jour le
parti socialiste parce qu'ils étaient le
parti socialiste éclaté et une branche
créé le parti communiste parce qu'il
trouvait le parti socialiste n'était pas
assez engagé dans la lutte et léon blum
était le gardien de la maison un
socialiste où il ne restait quasiment
plus personne et en 1936 il ya donc
voilà je crois un moment d'histoire dans
lequel on devrait sera qu'on doit se
rappeler et pour terminer le dernier
film que vous ayez vu voilà j'ai pas si
je dois vous dire parce que c'est
développe booster america pas que j'aime
bien les blockbusters américains
donc c'était de super héros j'ai déjà
oublié le nom là c'est black panther
mais quand j'y suis allé en réalité
presque
j'étais surpris par le phénomène que ça
a pris gt ça m'a surpris je cours pas
aller voir les blockbusters surtout
américains mais ça m'a surpris je me
suis dit pourquoi tant de gens vont voir
un ce film là et il ya la question aussi
du fait que ce soit un film où il ya
beaucoup d'acteurs afro américains ça
m'a interpellé
donc je me suis dit je vais aller voir
pour me faire une idée moi donc c'est le
dernier que j'ai vu merci ce sera le mot
de la fin merci merci si psa café
politique non c'est bien
[Musique]